so back in march this is where we
started to take our patients with
chronovirus into intensive care
dr efa abby admitted this hospital's
first
covered 19 patients now her critical
care unit dedicated to covered treatment
is empty this was a hive of activity
and just patient after patient
but she's watching the uk's rising
infections
with some trepidation what we are
holding our breath to see
if this spread in young people to see if
that actually
starts to translate into cases of those
who are more vulnerable
and certainly in this trust we are
getting ready
and all of the planning that we did
during the pandemic when it was at its
worst
we are still doing now not only are
infections rising
people are still dying this hospital
lost a patient to covid
just last month everyone hopes these
critical care beds will stay empty the
doctors here
will be looking at what's happening in
europe
during the peak of the pandemic we were
just a few weeks behind
what was happening over there being
repeated over here now
in france and spain infections are
rising
and so too are hospital admissions
after one of europe's strictest
lockdowns spaniards were desperate to
return to normality
but many blame the easing of
restrictions on this latest
rise in infections the new cases are
mostly younger people
who aren't becoming as sick as patients
earlier in the outbreak
but hospital admissions are climbing
at the very beginning of this second
wave we started affecting
younger people than in the first wave
after many cases that were
significantly younger we are now or
detecting again older patients
the situation now is is more controlled
that doesn't mean that in the in the
future if the number of cases in greece
we are going to be in problems again the
nhs has learned a lot about covid19
treatments are available and valuable
experience has been gained
but going back to where we were is just
not worth thinking about
the idea of having to go through it all
again is difficult to comprehend
from my point of view the psychological
toll on people was massive
and going to work every day in those
circumstances was hard the warning is uk
hospital admissions
will increase but we don't know by how
much
all we can do is be prepared university
hospital coventry
says it is joshi sky news